we're here in lovely San Mateo
California with Nick Bohr who's the
co-founder of Edmodo now can you just
explain to me really quickly what Edmodo
is absolutely Edmodo is the largest k12
social learning platform in the world
founded in 2008 we've grown to over 30
million teachers and students Edmodo is
used to create groups share content
share ideas basically take what's
happening in the classroom and make sure
that learning happens all day long so
for people who don't understand what
those words mean what is a social
learning platform so it really starts
with building simple products that
teachers and students want to use and in
this case when we founded moto we found
that folks were connected outside of the
classroom on lots of different devices
and platforms but when they got to the
classroom everyone was disconnected so
the classroom needed a a social platform
that recognized the specific roles in a
classroom teacher student parent
administrator provide functionality for
them and to make their lives easier when
you do that in a case of it mowed Oh
Lots and teachers everywhere have
adopted the platform told their friends
gotten more teachers on and we've built
now a social learning platform and that
platform this platform provides a way
for teachers to create groups and bring
their students on and do all the things
that they do in the classroom but in a
digital way and keep it very very simple
and that's really why teachers have
adopted adopted moto and such numbers
and and brought on other teachers so
this is sort of like you guys don't
create the actual content you don't
create the lessons or any of that sort
of thing so this is sort of like the
Facebook for classrooms where they're
uploading their own or buying their own
lesson plan it's an absolutely open
platform so user-generated content
coming from teachers and students it
also provides ways for publishers big
and small to get their content directly
to classrooms which has been a major
problem in the space when it comes to
why the speed of innovation hasn't been
where we'd like it to be media is
evolving so fast outside the classroom
to get that to happen inside the
classroom you need a platform you need a
network that allows for the best content
to rise to the top now you started this
when
were in college you were junior college
e-tolling we started this how did this I
you were just if you were studying and
this idea came from where so I started
working in the IT department at at my
high school as a sophomore and kind of
worked my way up this is Kailen high
school in the suburbs of Chicago Kayla
yes that's the nights I saw every day
the incredible effort that teachers were
making in the classrooms to to reach
their students and and saw that if they
had simple tools to help that engagement
that they would spread it like wildfire
and in the past folks had always built
these kinds of tools or systems and then
tried to go school at a time from the
top down definitely saw that going from
the bottom up will allow you to grow
much faster and that scale is what is so
important to providing the power of them
whether with any sort of network and
they say and you told me the revenue
model is basically it's a revenue share
like so there's a sort of an app store
for lessons and so forth has have been
hard to get a for-profit company into
the educational space so you know we
support and our partners with companies
of all different types for us the reason
for being for profit is the staying
power we want to prove prove out that we
can drive this innovation for the long
term and really change the way that
content gets to classrooms so we only
have a minute or two left but you've
raised a lot of money you brave nearly
60 million dollars from a bunch of
gold-plated VCS and you told me you how
many people working here now 115 so
you've been growing gangbusters so if
you're gonna fast forward and it's now
five years from now one are you still
running at moto into what is that moto
doing so Edmodo is focused on learning
and I think more and more now that we
have this network at a scale that's
that's incredibly powerful we can start
to do some pretty amazing things around
student growth our mission is really to
connect every learner with the people
and resources they need to reach their
full potential and so will absolutely be
doing that and I will be doing whatever
they allow me to do here to contribute
in a way that's possible well I'll come
back and visit you in five years thank
you so much Nick yeah thank you